[Music]
unfortunately we have to deal with a
heavy topic for the daily cancellation
today it's heavy uh but it's also um
a big topic and one that can be
difficult to fully kind of wrap your
arms around here's the story from the
daily mail they report that a morbidly
obese traveler quote has divided opinion
after sharing a viral tick tock slamming
ryanair for the size of its seats with
some critics telling her it was not the
airline's fault
now it's basically a monthly tradition
at this point that a fat airline
passenger complains on tick tock about
the fact that planes are not being
redesigned to specifically accommodate
their hefty frame uh this is right in
line with those other complaints the
daily mail continues kirsty leanne
kirstyland29 from shropshire filmed the
clip while flying with the budget
carrier revealing how she struggled to
fit down the plane's narrow aisle
couldn't use the tray table due to lack
of space and could barely move in the
tiny toilet cubicle kirsty who blogs
about her experiences traveling as a
size 24 to 26 wanted to highlight issues
she encounters to others recalling the
problematic flight kirsty explained the
first issue i faced was walking down the
plane aisle i was one of the last people
on the plane because i was running a
little late so i felt the stares of
people all i could think was that they
didn't want me to sit next to them the
plus size blogger also revealed how she
was unable to do work because she didn't
have space to use the tray table she
said i was going to use the tray table
to do some work on the way but when i
couldn't put it down i quickly decided
that it was not going to happen
meanwhile she continued the bathroom was
another issue i faced unfortunately it's
probably one of the smallest bathrooms
i've ever seen and i decided against
trying to squeeze in
she continues with this horror story in
greater detail but you probably get the
the gist apparently kirsty does this for
a living or at least as a hobby she
travels around and complains when she's
too fat to do certain things according
to her tick tock account
her mission is to push for greater
plus-sized representation in the travel
industry
although you could argue that plus-sized
people already have
you know very large representation
now we've talked plenty of times in the
past about the so-called body positivity
movement which encourages people to
display their positive attitudes about
their bodies by destroying their bodies
this is what makes body positivity one
of the most self-contradictory and also
destructive ideas to come along in quite
some time and it manages to stand out
even amid all the other
self-contradictory destructive ideas
that are so popular these days
but we're not going to dwell
specifically on that aspect of it
we're also going to leave aside the
point that if i'm being honest part of
me actually hopes that the obese
community gets their way plays the
victim card successfully and forces
planes to better accommodate them
because the end result is that we would
all get bigger seats and more legroom i
guess which would be kind of nice of
course that's assuming that the
concession doesn't involve setting aside
a special area on the plane just for fat
people where only they get the extra
room maybe first class will be abolished
and replaced with fat class
fat people will be rewarded with you
know premium first class seats and even
better the first class food
so come to think of it that's actually
probably exactly what would end up
happening so i take back what i said a
moment ago
anyway i want to turn our attention to
another aspect of this situation which
lies a little deeper and you can only
see it when you sort of
trim the fat away no pun intended of
course i'm not the kind of person who
would bring up this discussion
as nothing more than a vehicle to make
fat puns that's not who i am instead i'm
struck by
the important truth about human nature
that this story and stories like it
illustrate for us
after all the fat acceptance movement is
supposed to be all about
freedom right
people should be free to be whatever
size they want and the world's job is to
accommodate their girth however
gargantuan it might be
but as always
our culture promotes a kind of freedom
which is really in the end slavery
when you do whatever you want you
exercise no self-control
you exercise
not at all in general
and simply follow the whims of the flesh
you end up trapped in a nightmare of
your own making
this woman is so free that you can't
even fit on a plane she's so free that
you can't fully participate in society
she's so free that she's probably gonna
die before she reaches the age of 60.
this is the freedom of the modern world
the freedom that makes you a slave to
your compulsions the freedom that leads
ultimately to annihilation
and fat acceptance is just one example
there are many others often quite a bit
more serious how about to return to the
topic of the day
the freedom granted to women to kill
their unborn children
this is a freedom that deprives you of
something good and true and fulfilling
it deprives a woman of herself in many
ways it deprives her of the opportunity
to be transformed by the love for and
from her child
it robs her of everything
consigns her to a life of regret and
loss and guilt
and then we call it
freedom
dostoevsky noticed this about the modern
world way back in the 1800s when he
wrote the brothers karamazov which
includes this passage
he writes the world has proclaimed the
reign of freedom especially of late but
what do we see in this freedom of theirs
nothing but slavery and self-destruction
for the world says you have desires and
so satisfy them for you have the same
rights as the most rich and powerful
don't be afraid of satisfying them and
even multiplying your desires
that is the modern doctrine of the world
in that they see freedom
and what follows from this rite of
multiplication of desire in the rich
isolation and spiritual suicide in the
poor envy and murder for they have been
given rights but have not been shown the
means of satisfying their wants
they maintain that the world is getting
more and more united more and more bound
together in brotherly community as it
overcomes distance and sets thoughts
flying through the air
but put no faith in such a bond of union
interpreting freedom as the
multiplication and rapid satisfaction of
desire
men distort their own nature for many
senseless and foolish desires and habits
and ridiculous fancies are fostered in
them now dostoevsky noticed this about
western culture as he observed it from
russia in the year 1880
and he couldn't have known just how
right he was
there's probably never been a better
definition of the modern conception of
freedom than the one that he offers
right there freedom is the
multiplication and satisfaction of
desire
but that's not freedom at all it is as
he points out isolation envy hatred
suicide
that's what this kind of freedom gets
you
you aren't even free
to walk down the aisle of a passenger
plane you're left hampered disabled
helpless
screaming out like a child demanding
that the world conform itself to you
you're not gonna find any freedom in
such a life
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated